من السعوديه الى تونس نذهب الى الفوز
المستحق ايضا والاداء المشرف قدمه المنتخب
التونسي في اخر مبارياته امام المنتخب
الفرنسي بطل العالم في النسخه السابقه من
المونديال تونس لعبت الفوز وحققت المعجزه
بتحقيقها امام المنتخب الفرنسي القوي
لكنها خسرت حدود التاهل مع فوز استراليا
المنتخب التونسي قدم
اداه وقارعه ابرز نجوم العالم مثل باقي
جريزمان وغيرهم ليخرج باداء ارضى جماهيرا
سور قرطاج التي هتفت لمنتخبتها بفرح رغم
الخروج ودفع المنتخب التونسي ثمنا خسارته
الغريبه امام استراليا في الجوله الماضيه
لتستمر سلسله الخروج التونسيه من الدور
الاول في المونديال على كل حال كل هذه
الاجواء معك يا احلام لعبداليه الى تونس
طيور الجنه
[ضحك]
صباح
القديش حتى واحد
ان شاء الله
ان شاء الله على الاخر
بيوم انتصار بالتاريخ البارحه حكم مكتوب
ذهب
واحد مش فاهم روحه توا يفرح اما برجوليا
الوليه
الكوره تونس
[موسيقى]
انا بقى ما طلع شاحنيش معنيه واستراليا
رابحه
ياخذوا لي احنا ارباحنا ما كناش متوقرينها
همم فما انت يا اختي بالحق نحس فيها
تونس المسابقات الاخرى وباكو غاز للمغرب
شو اسمه المغرب
الجوز كبير برشا برشا
النهارده
يلا قول
هيه
المنتخب الوطني التونسي
الانتخاب بطل العالم مفاجاه ابهرت العالم
اليوم اختتام يوم طويل وذهب
قنابل فرح والمرح هنا رغبه مغادره
المونديال يواجه التونسيون الاحتفالات في
ليله من الليالي التي اكيد وانها لن تنسى
اكيد مباراه لن تنسى بعد الفوز المشرف
تونس تبهر العالم باداء المميز مباراه
للذكرى امام فرنسا لكن ما هي حكايه تونس
مع الدور الاول المنتخب التونسي ودع
المونديال من دوري المجموعات المره
السادسه في تاريخ مشاركته في المونديال
فوست تونس هو الاول لها على منتخب اوروبي
في تاريخ المونديال في ما كانت خساره
فرنسا الاولى امام منتخب عربي في كاس
العالم تونس وادعه المونديال المره
الثانيه في تاريخها بعد مونديال عام
1978 من تحقيق نفس النتائج
وتعادل وخساره
مهاجم المنتخب التونسي وهبي الخزري يصبح
ثاني لاعب عربي سجن في مونديال مختلفين
معادلا ايضا نجم الكره السعوديه السابق
سامي الجابر بتسجيل ثلاثه اهداف في تاريخ
المشاركاته في المونديال
دراغون بول اسمع
بيومتين
يشويه طاسه الاحتلال وقت الشده في سوده
[تصفيق]
شكرا
عبد الرحمن تسمعني
عبد الرحمن على كل المستمر
[موسيقى]
عبد الرحمن اسمعني الحين
اهلا بك عبد الرحمن كلنا نتحدث عن
اللاعب المشرف لتونس وخروجها من المونديال
خروج مشرف اداء مميز كيف تقيمون مباراه
الامس اداء المنتخب التونسي ولماذا لم
يلعب بنفس المستوى على الاقل في المباراه
السابقه ليضمن التاهل
يبدو انه عندنا مشكله بالصوت مع عبد
الرحمن على الكل يشكره على تواجدوا معنا
من الدوحه
اسمعكم ايه
طب سمعت سؤال عبد الرحمن ولا عيده
المنتخب التونسي يمكن الفوز كان مشاعر
مختلطه ما بين الفرح والحسره الفرح بفوز
على منتخب فرنسا بطل العالم النسخه
الماضيه
والحسره يمكن على على عدم تاهل وهو تاهل
كان مستحق يعني اربع نقاط بعد فوز على همم
بعد التعادل مع الدنمارك وايضا تقديم
مستوى جيد نوع امام استراليا المنتخبات
العربيه يعني تلعب تعتبر تلعب على ارضها
يعني بين جمهور والجمهور العربي كان يعني
كان ميزه في هذا المونديال همم اعتقد ان
المنتخب التونسي بحاجه نوعا ما الى الى
تجديد الدماء يعني وضع همم يعني او خلق
جيل جديد جديد مطاعم ببعض الهجوم الخبره
يمكن الاغلب كان يحمل المدرب المنتخب همم
يعني عدم التاهل لكن اعتقد ان المنتخب
التونسي يقدم اداء جيد في ست نسخ ماضيه من
المونديال متاكد النسخه هذه كانت هي
الاميز همم قدم اداء جيد همم يعني همم
باضافه الى منتخبات العربيه همم يعني لم
يكن المنتخب التونسي بحاجه الا الى
التوفيق والحظ فقط امام استراليا ان يصل
للمنتخب التونسي الى الى التنافس بعد ان
كانت مشاركاته السابقه ومشاركات تشريفيه
اذا قلنا هذا ثالث فوز للمنتخب التونسي في
المونديال وايضا يسجل له همم يعني همم
باذن الله ان تكون المشاركات المقبله
المنتخبات العربيه جيده
رفع رعايه المنتخبات العربيه
ايضا يعني كانت مشاركه مشرفه للسعوديه لكن
اليوم هذا التراجع في الحماس نوعا ما كيف
يمكن قراءه رياضيا خصوصا اذا ما تبعنا من
المباراه الاولى مع الارجنتين ومن ثم
بولندا ومن ثم ما حصل امس مع المكسيك يعني
اين كانت الثغرات ونقاط الخلل
المنتخب السعودي
على المنتخب الارجنتيني ما كان يتوقع ان
يقدم اداء رائع امام بولندا وان يكون اكثر
واقعيه صحيح المدرب المنتخب السيد رينارد
قد يكون اخطانا في تشكيله المنتخب وتغيير
المراكز في مباراه امام المكسيك لكن لا
نقفل نقدمه المنتخب لا يقبل ان يلعب امام
منتخب همم ثالث افضل منتخب في العالم نجوم
العالم همم يعني اعتقد ان اعتقلنا من
مرحله المشاركه تشريفيه ايضا الى المشاركه
التنافسيه اغلب النسخ الماضيه كنا نصل الى
الجوله الثالثه ونحن نفاقديه الامل لان لا
اصبحنا ننافس اصبحت المنتخبات تعمل 1,000
حساب حتى انظار العالم بالبحث عن كره
القدم السعوديه عن اللاعبين السعوديين عن
هويه المنتخب السعودي اصبحنا لدينا لاعبين
لديهم ثقه حتى هذا يدل على وهذا الجيل حتى
هذا الجيل يعني يعتبرنا محظوظ بوجود دعم
لا محدود وغير مسبوق من الحكومه دعم من
الوسائل الاعلام دعم من الجمهور دعم من
الجميع فهذا اعتقد انه كان رد جميل
المنتخب هذا قدم في التصفيات ارقام قياسيه
لم تقدم في تاريخ كره القدم السعوديه
اعتقد ان الجميع كان راضيه عن هذا الاداء
صحيح انه لم يكن راضي بعدم التاهل لكنه في
نفس الوقت الاداء الذي قدم والتنافس
الكبير كان شيء يعني يحسب للمنتخب السعودي
كمنظومه كامله وليس المدرب فقط اللاعبين
استطاع هذا المدرب ان يخرج ما في جعبه
اللاعبين من حماس من اداء من ثقه من جميع
الامور التي كان يعمل عليها في الاشهر
الماضيه كانت المنتخب كان المنتخب السعودي
مع مجموعه قويه لا يستهان فيها وكانت
ترشيحات كلها تجعلها اخر ومتغير بالترتيب
لكن يقدم درس لجميع المنتخبات وحتى اضافه
حماس لبقيه المنتخبات العربيه بحكم من اول
المنتخبات او ثاني المنتخبات اللي شاركت
في المونديال او في في ثالث جوله تقريبا
والدعم وجعل الحماس اكبر لدى المنتخبات
العربيه وحتى المنتخبات الاسيويه لبعضها
قدمت مستويات جيده